y
[Música]
atala hand broker renunció a su cargo
como primer ministro de sudán este
domingo murieron al menos dos personas
durante una nueva jornada de
manifestaciones contra el golpe de
estado del 25 de octubre de 2021
choques entre manifestantes y policías
en ámsterdam una multitud salió a las
calles este domingo para protestar
contra las restricciones de porco vídeo
19 en países bajos autoridades le
reportan al menos 30 detenidos
en colombia fueron asesinados 171
líderes sociales en 2021 según la
organización in the path el hecho más
reciente ocurrió en nochevieja cuando
maría del carmen molina fue atacada por
un grupo de hombres armados y en
presencia de su propia familia
un cordial saludo para todos
actualizamos las noticias más
importantes de la jornada en france 24
los saludo a danger hablando comenzamos
hablando de abdalá hanbok quien renunció
como primer ministro de ciudad este
domingo al menos dos personas murieron
durante enfrentamientos con las fuerzas
de seguridad en una nueva manifestación
contra el golpe militar de octubre de
2021 con lo que la cifra de muertos se
eleva a 56 desde el inicio de las
protestas
he decidido anunciar mi renuncia al
lindo como
allanando el camino para que otro hombre
o mujer del pueblo de nuestro generoso
país
continúe con el liderazgo de nuestro
amado país de botones nazis y es que
hasta la hand oca había regresado al
cargo hace sólo seis semanas tras un
acuerdo con los militares que en octubre
lo habían depuesto en el golpe de estado
que originó las protestas pero no
consiguió formar gobierno este es su
perfil
para algunos abdalá hand of firmó un
pacto con el [__] otros lo acusan de
haber vendido la revolución este 21 de
noviembre el primer ministro de ciudad
volvió a asumir el cargo en el seno del
consejo de soberanía que dirigía el
hombre que lo había derrocado casi un
mes antes el general al burhan donde más
robusto cuando acepte el cargo de primer
ministro de la transición yo sabía
perfectamente que el camino no estaría
lleno de rosas y que la ruta sería
difícil el camino y atajando finalmente
terminó ante la desconfianza de una
población cansada de los compromisos con
los militares
rechazamos toda forma de golpe de estado
incluyendo si eso implica el regreso
dejando que al gobierno nuestra gloriosa
revolución de diciembre de 2018 tuvo
lugar para conseguir un gobierno civil
en su totalidad
abdalá cuando fue nombrado primer
ministro de la transición representaba
esperanza nació en 1956 en el sur del
país es un economista que trabajó en
naciones unidas no se encontraba en
ciudad en el momento de la revolución
rechazó el cargo de ministro de finanzas
que omar al bashir ya había propuesto en
2018 con la caída del dictador en abril
de 2019 las autoridades de transición
heredaron un país en quiebra abdalá
hanbok fue depuesto por los militares el
pasado 25 de octubre junto con los otros
miembros civiles de su ejecutivo bajo el
pretexto de no haber podido frenar esta
crisis económica pero los sudaneses no
quisieron ceder y el regreso dejando en
el consejo soberano levantó voces
discordantes las manifestaciones no
cesaron pese a la represión de la junta
en el poder
y seguimos en este continente para
hablar esta vez de sudáfrica que se
produce en donde se produjo un incendio
de grandes magnitudes en la sede del
parlamento en ciudad del cabo
destruyendo oficinas y provocando el
desplome de algunos techos las
autoridades aseguran que la
conflagración inició en uno de los
edificios más antiguos y luego se
trasladó a otros espacios una persona
sospechosa de causar la conflagración
fue detenida y es interrogada por las
autoridades
miles de personas se reunieron en
amsterdam para protestar contra las
restricciones por covite 19 en países
bajos este país se encuentra desde el 19
de diciembre en un confinamiento
estricto con el que se decretó el cierre
de toda actividad no esencial hasta el
14 de enero la manifestación sin embargo
siguió adelante a pesar de estar
prohibida por las autoridades la policía
local detalló en un comunicado que al
menos 30 personas fueron detenidas
después de protagonizar riñas con
agentes de seguridad 4 de los cuales
resultaron heridos y
yo también soy dueña de una empresa de
repostería y para mí es muy importante
que pueda abrir
porque no estoy de acuerdo con el
gobierno en este momento
entonces quiero abrir para que vengan
nuestros clientes para que disfruten y
se diviertan
porque todo se acabó la diversión no
está aquí queremos divertirnos juntos y
ser felices y libres es muy importante
para mí
de vuelta a casa los 2.844 pasajeros y
1.353 tripulantes a bordo de un crucero
alemán con destino final a islas
canarias serán devueltos por vía aérea a
sus países de origen tras detectar un
brote de kobe de 19 pasajeros de la isla
no va salieron el 29 de diciembre hacia
el archipiélago de madeira en portugal
para ver los fuegos artificiales de fin
de año y dirigirse después a lanzarote
sin embargo quedaron atascados en un
puerto de lisboa el 31 de diciembre
después de que se detectaran casos
positivos de kobe de 19 que hoy
ascienden a 64 todos de ellos
asintomáticos o con síntomas leves la
empresa alemana operadora del crucero
decidió cancelar el récord
y justamente la pandemia de kobe de 19 a
la por la variante omicron será uno de
los retos en 2022 para el presidente de
francia de manuel macro pero no es el
único en el primer semestre del año el
mandatario deberá liderar la presidencia
rotativa de la unión europea y al mismo
tiempo tendrá que afianzarse el en en el
electorado si espera lanzarse a la red
de leer a la reelección informe manuel
acá no
un año crucial y desafiante así se
perfila el 2022 para emanuel marcó con
el primer día del año ya llegó un gran
reto su presidencia rotativa de la unión
europea que catalogó como un punto de
inflexión apasionado mínimo a partir de
la medianoche francia asumirá la
presidencia rotativa de la unión europea
y pueden contar con mi compromiso total
a pesar de su optimismo marco deberá
liderar al bloque europeo inmerso en un
complejo panorama con la crisis
sanitaria que sigue azotando a europa y
la reciente escalada de la tensión entre
ucrania y rusia aún así parece que el
presidente tiene sus principales
objetivos claros buscará el
establecimiento
varios mínimos en toda europa la
regulación de los gigantes digitales y
la creación de un impuesto al carbono
además de la protección de las fronteras
europeas frente a las crisis migratorias
un liderazgo que podría verse afectado
por su propia pugna presidencial el
mandatario no ha anunciado aún su
candidatura que muchos ven como
ineludibles un gesto que podría deberse
a su deseo de no mezclar sus decisiones
políticas con su campaña presidencial su
carrera por hacerse de nuevo con el
elíseo ya tiene un importante obstáculo
la candidatura de la conservadora
valérie pécresse es su principal rival
que se ha afianzado en una parte del
electorado mi deseo por tanto es que en
la próxima primavera las elecciones
presidenciales sean de convicciones y
verdaderas soluciones para francia cerca
de dos años de pandemia han golpeado
duramente al mandatario que además de
seguir lidiando con el aumento de los
casos deberá luchar contra la caída de
su popularidad en colombia la lidereza
social maría del carmen molina imbachí
fue asesinada en nochevieja por un grupo
de hombres armados y en presencia de su
familia
el instituto de indepaz informó que se
trató del asesinato número 171 de líder
sociales en este año previamente
hablamos con camilo gonzález posso
presidente de indepaz quien nos explicó
en qué está fallando el estado pues son
muchos los factores no porque en todo
caso hay que señalar que del año 2021
comparado con el año 2020 hay una
disminución en otros indicadores de
asesinato de líderes y de ex
combatientes que están reincorporándose
pero las políticas son insuficientes
sobre todo porque no están acompañadas
de políticas sociales y porque no hay un
verdadero esfuerzo de desmantelar no
solamente el grupos armados sino los que
están atrás son de intereses muy
poderosos de mafias de narcotráfico de
gente que está en el lado de activos que
se incrustaba de los poderes políticos y
en cambio por la orientación de
seguridad se dirige solamente a la
cúpula de grupos armados criminales como
lo que habría que hacer un
replanteamiento en este año las
comunidades en el país en muchos
sectores están proponiendo un pacto por
la vida están exigiendo un acatamiento
incondicional de las normas de derecho
humanitario que se haya un cese al fuego
de hostilidades en medio de la campaña
electoral que viene y a esto se ha
sumado en muchos sectores incluso los
monseñores de la iglesia católica en el
sector pacífico colombiano se han unido
a ese llamamiento de un pacto
humanitario y de hacer de la vida un
compromiso de todos los que están con
responsabilidades y en campañas
políticas en este primer trimestre
y a sus 60 y 77 años murió el
paleoantropólogo keniano richard leakey
responsable de destacados aportes para
comprender la evolución humana era hijo
de dos paleontólogos y en
1984 estuvo presente en el
descubrimiento por parte de un miembro
de su equipo del famoso niño de turkana
quien era un esqueleto completo de un
niño de entre 9 y 12 años que falleció
hace 16 millones
con esto despedimos este informativo los
invitamos a que continúen con nosotros
en france 24 y france24 puntocom
[Música]